all right so
uh sims put out a tweet yesterday
morning one of the best silliest
weirdest dumbest sports bar debates
you've gotten into
we'll answer the best ones on the next
pod so we've co-opted that for this show
apparently this is an outgrowth of the
how many aaron donalds oh wait how many
florios would you rather
fight than aaron donald yeah these are
common themes on my podcast where we
bring up stupid i got some
negative feedback on the fact that that
we actually wasted time on the show
talking about that uh
well who didn't like you you need to
change your email
okay and stop worrying about that
we could give out we could travel
through time
get the winning powerball numbers come
back
you're right and give them out on the
show and there would still be people who
complain oh you're
you're exactly right and they big you're
an idiot they're wrong i still
i won 50 million from the powerball but
you were wrong i mean yeah it's just the
way
it's the way the world is right now i
don't know and that's that's been i
i remember with the website years ago i
used to say i could give out 100
bills and someone would complain they're
not crisp enough yeah that's just
yes that's just the way the way we are
it hasn't gotten any better over the
last 12 years that's for damn sure okay
so here we go at holdacre
phil and eli should both be in the hall
of fame
based on troy aikman getting in look at
the numbers
and troy had a lot more help maybe the
greatest offensive line in nfl history
and the all-time
leading rusher now look troy aikman's
passing numbers not great but
he's got the three super bowls he was
the quarterback of
one of the great dynasties one of the
last dynasties
of the pre-free agency the patriots are
the only ones since free agency
um look at the numbers i you know
i yeah if if if he's in
why we i i think eli manning's getting
in because his name's manning right and
i think peyton's already started
lobbying the voters to get eli in
phil's the one that could make the
argument yeah if troy's in
phil should be in yeah but phil ain't
ever going to make the argument you know
phil's just not that way he's not one
that's going to politic
and do that type of stuff listen
obviously i'm biased to this
this one yeah there's a few quarterbacks
i could look at through the through
history and go well
i think it's pretty close if he's in
maybe my father should be in
you know but either way troy aikman
deserves to be in we know that i don't
care about the team or anything like
that
listen you know joe montana won four
super bowls last time i checked he kind
of had a good players around him
too i mean it's part of it so he wasn't
asked to
necessarily carry the team with his
right arm all the time
but he also i could argue and go man the
style of football he was asked to play
sometimes even like my father
is hard for a quarterback oh run the
ball in first run the ball a second hey
it's third and ten can you throw a rifle
in there now
i mean that's what troy and my dad had
to do a lot of the times
it wasn't about just getting the shotgun
and do that so hey i think of my dad
you know i'm with you i think eli gets
in um
i think it's on the fence just like my
father a little bit i think my dad would
be in if he played in that second super
bowl
and got to play and win that against the
buffalo bills i don't think there's any
doubt but like
aikman namath kurt warner
you know i look at those guys to go i
think my dad's right there with them and
you know
i know not everybody agrees with that
well in a team sport it is a huge impact
what team you end up on
yes and uh hey look phil could have been
on a team
that won zero super balls or he could
have been on a team that won four
yep and and right place right time has a
lot to do with it but
but his numbers and his achievements
what he did in super bowl 21
you could argue in and of itself
deserves consideration it was one of the
all-time great single game performances
in nfl history
yeah it was yeah no i mean you know
again there's a lot of things we can sit
here and be positive with big phil about
certainly i mean they had a run of the
playoffs you know the giants were
in that cream of the crop teams that we
talked about where they were one of the
five or six teams that could
win the super bowl every year and of
course they were playing in the toughest
division in football i mean maybe the
toughest division in the history of
football
that's where i think people you know
that and then he had also played the
49ers every year and deal with that and
all that so
uh i don't know in my heart of hearts i
don't think my dad will ever get in now
at this point it's just not sexy enough
anything like that
but uh of course you know i i think he
should be
i thought of something while you were
talking about your dad's accomplishments
and it reminded me of something
that someone pointed out yesterday that
gives us
the parallel to matthew stafford
remember we were trying to figure out
who who if anyone was a quarterback that
played for
crap team and then ended up on a great
team
and had a dramatic change in his career
and i thought of this guy because you
mentioned two super bowl wins well
there's one quarterback who has two
super bowl wins
who ain't in the hall of fame jim
plunkett right and he's the guy
he's the guy that toiled with bad teams
before he landed in oakland
and was it it was oakland before they
even went to la that's how long ago it
was
before they went to la the first time
and won a couple of super bowls with the
raiders
i mean that's one i've never understood
you know jim plunkett won two super
bowls like i i know
his stats and everything aren't going to
look that great
but like your points real nobody's stats
were going to look that great with some
of the teams he had to play on he played
on the crappiest of the crappy teams in
the nfl
then he got to another team that was
better and could support his talents a
little bit
and yeah he wins the super bowl with
oakland and mate the second one i think
was la right in 83 that was they were
the la raiders in that one
but like yeah jack squire game yeah
right i never understand any of that i
mean tom forest just got in
what he just got in he won two super
bowls
he's just getting in that makes no sense
at all so i i don't get that sometimes i
don't get you know
who gets in or why this guy got in first
or last or anything like that
um but it seems like two super bowls is
pretty much a baseline
like for quarterback if you have that
you get in and jim plunkett is never
discussed
here's another question as it relates to
phil sims from
attw steve in the early 90s i
argued that your dad was a better
statistical quarterback than joe namath
against a bar full of oiled up jets fans
they yelled me they out yelled me but i
was right
still am let's see the stats to compare
the joe namath career and the phil sims
career now look nameth played in a
different era
yeah but but like there's no comparison
in the stats injuries cut his career
short he was the first guy to ever throw
for 4 000 yards and
he made the guarantee super bowl three
legitimized the afl
big deal biggest moment in nfl history
at that time
for the jets to pull off that win and i
think that that that
that carries them and having white shoes
that helps you get there too yeah
you you can't like tell the story of the
nfl without joe namath and that lo i
mean
it was he just got some unbelievably
marquee
special moments yeah when you look at
his career as a whole
it's underwhelming i mean he threw 47
more interceptions and he threw
touchdown passes
so he wasn't exactly the greatest
decision maker in the history of
football either
but man i you know it's again
the hall of fame is about elite and he
was had an elite arm
a quick release he was like the dan
marino of his day like whoa
i've never seen a guy get the ball up
and out with that kind of power
you know uh it just looks different and
that's what he was little
lonely at the bravado to go along with
it the guarantee everything like that
but
yes again that's why i said his name
before and i do believe my dad is in
that class
you know i don't know everybody else is
going to believe that but that that's at
least what i believe
one thing i noticed yeah that i'd never
noticed before
in those clips we just played what what
was up with the referee was he trying to
to lift joe namath's wallet did you
notice that no it's like right
on top of him and backpedaling like the
referee
is positioned pre-play now a good what
seven yards behind the action yeah you
see you see the referee like the
referee's right up on joe namath that
he's backpedaling as joe namath goes
into
his drop i just never noticed that
before and i saw it twice that's
hilarious i did not notice it but joe
namath again
yes i think my dad should be in the
super bowl i mean in the super bowl
he was there in the hall of fame but i
certainly am not making the case that
joe namath watch the referee here
yeah what's the referee where well maybe
maybe oh there he is
maybe maybe uh maybe but there's a
little shuffle along with him like so he
could
see the next one there's more of a back
pedal where is he where is he oh yeah
he's close enough there i see him though
i saw him yeah
okay it was it was you know what it
would have been better if we hadn't
shown it
but it was wrong i i admit
i admit i was wrong okay go ahead no i i
got nothing else to say i mean
namath just has a few of those marquee
moments that are just too special and
that's why he got in the hall of fame
definitely
uh there's no doubt yeah you know he was
special there's still hope for phil
there's still hope for phil yeah but
phil is like the kind of guy that's like
oh i didn't get in the hell with it
screw the screw the hall of fame and all
that like it's just he just he's not not
that he says screw it but he just is
like
he's not gonna call call people try to
get other media
members to put themselves out there you
know again
look behind the curtain this is kind of
what goes on at the hall of fame other
than like the peyton manning's in the
brett farms the world they don't have to
call anybody we know that
but like the rest of these people are
putting together a campaign to get into
the hall of fame
they all do it's all a part of a big
process
and that's where big phil you'll you'll
never see him do that he won't
let me just say this and this is not
going to be a popular
comment for for some but i'm going to
say it because it's the truth
to me the pro football hall of fame was
a very
magical mystical
special idea until i went there
and that's that changed at all it's like
what's what's what's the big deal it's a
museum
and it really isn't that nice and i know
they've put a lot into it
in the past 10 years i was there in 2005
and i was stunned at how
ordinary it was um now the room with all
the bus is a big deal but
look it's it's a museum in a small town
in ohio
and its existence is driven by having a
ceremony every year where they put a
bunch of new bus in
and that's it and there's it's a team
sport i
i and your dad's got the right attitude
it really doesn't matter
what matters is the super bowl ring what
matters is what he experienced what
matters is
his career and it doesn't need to be
validated
by a bust of that messed up hairdo that
he had at moorhead stuff
yeah no although that would be that
would be a very hot bus
really would be they have a hard time
figuring that out on uh that piece of
bronze or whatever
that ugly hairdo he had it's gonna take
a lot of bronze
you can have a lot of extra bronze to do
the phil sims hairdo from the 1970s all
right
mitch mike matt and
i have a feeling this is matt casey's
burner account the vikings should have
kept case keenum instead of signing kirk
cousins trust me lots of vikings fans
just don't get it hey like you don't you
don't need
they hear it from me i've already said
it they should have stuck with case
kingdom he took him to the
brink of the super bowl he showed he
could get it done they could have kept
him for a hell of a lot less money than
what they paid kirk cousins and what
have they gotten out of kirk cousins in
three seasons
one playoff appearance big deal yeah
there's certainly a case it's certainly
the great case of like
you know i i think we over exaggerate
the importance of the franchise
quarterback and all of that
that's one that would jump out to go
well you know kirk cousins is really
good you're right
but i don't know if it's necessarily
translated to any better results for
that football team
for the most part than what they would
have got from case canada like obviously
he's better than case keenum i do
believe that there's no doubt i mean
he's underrated i think as a thrower
and some of the big plays he makes with
his right arm you know
but i i don't know if he's yeah special
enough to where i would have abandoned
ship with what case keenum was doing
to go wait we don't want you and we want
another guy that's yeah better
and we're gonna pay him 20 million
dollars more per year and make it harder
to support the quarterback with the rest
of our team and all that i mean
i hear that the case there i do you know
i think there's
there's too much of that in the nfl he's
always looking for
oh let me find the quarterback the
quarterback we got the quarterback so he
can't blame us that's not we got the
quarterback
no just build the freaking team and the
quarterback will look good uh
two too many times it's it's switched
around or backwards
what a weird time that was the vikings
almost get to the super bowl they have
teddy bridgewater case keenum and sam
bradford all become free agents they
sign
back none of them and go get kirk
cousins and make him at the time the
highest paid player in league history
easy money chives my friend and i got
into a physical altercation
because i said ed reed was better than
brian dawkins which is just
a factual statement this one's not going
to be easy for me i don't know i think
they're
the same they're different in what they
bring to a team
but i'd take either one wouldn't you uh
definitely
either one no doubt about it um
i mean they're both in the conversation
for the best safeties in the history of
football
i think when i just off the top of my
head here and i know i'm gonna forget
people
but you know ed reed you know
uh brian dawkins troy palamalu
ronnie lott right those i think are the
four that come to my mind right off the
bat
at least from my era of growing up and
everything like that and then
man i mean i played against all of them
i i don't know i i guess i'm going to
give the advantage to ed reed it's close
brian
dawkins is better in the run game but ed
reed was so
special in the past game and the pass
game was what was the most essential
part of football when he was playing
probably where i give ed reed just a
little advantage there
that guy that makes you hold on to the
football for another half second just to
make sure you you know where he is
i i that would always be my concern with
troy paula muller because you never know
where he's gonna pop up
so you end up holding onto the ball a
little bit longer and you get hit
yeah yeah oh it's it's that's the impact
of having a great safety like that
in the back end definitely they can do
so many things they're great erasers
those guys i mean they can be down there
in the box playing linebacker you say
set hut
they have enough speed and ability to
get back and now play the cover 2 safety
and get back there and
man we called the play because he was
down here to stop the run
and now he's talented enough to get back
there in coverage and we're screwed
i mean it was torture preparing uh for
ed reed and troy paloma
i didn't really have to prepare for uh
dawkins i played with him
i know what he's all about and
everything like that but like yes you
never knew where ed reed and paula mall
were gonna go
they didn't always follow the the called
play on defense either that's what was
scary
i mean ed reed i have a game in in 2006
to lead off the year
it's cover two he's on that side of the
football field i say set hut
i'm gonna throw a slant route over here
to michael clayton for like a six yard
gain
i'm getting ready to throw it and the
ball is coming out of my hands and i'm
going
like you know one of those where you're
like please come back ball because ed
reed was over there
he just he just had a hunch and went for
it and he should have picked it off he
dropped the ball but
yeah it's just that that's scary as hell
is a quarterback when you don't know
where the hell that guy's gonna be
it's that instinct that's the product of
talent
and film study and preparation and
recognition and it all comes together in
that moment you do get that hunch and
you're willing to act on it you know
which ones to act on and which ones to
ignore
the one thing about brian dawkins though
that presence
oh it's real locker room that presence
before a game
i remember there was one of the madden
games where they have him at the
beginning can you feel that
you know and it just it it gets you it
gets you fired up just powering up the
stupid madden game
i can imagine what he can do to a a team
as they're getting ready to take the
field oh please let me let me tell you
what he can do
i mean it's it's one of my great
memories
of my nfl career is brian dawkins
it's it was unbelievable first off i you
know me i'm a fan i was like man brian
dawkins is our team he's awesome this is
so cool
hall of famer everything like that
couldn't be nicer
i mean all week you know hey chris how
you doing yeah bless you but you know
you just
couldn't be a softer more quiet guy then
you walk in the locker room in denver on
sunday morning and we might have a two
o'clock game right
and we're getting there it's 11 30. he's
already taped up got his pants on
and he's and he's doing cartwheels
around the locker room
and he's getting in wolverine positions
and squatting down and jumping around
like it's the most unbelievable game day
transformation i saw from any player
and then the next day he was back to
like church school brian dawkins on a
monday
uh amazing it really was it is amazing
and uh look
you can't go wrong with either guy but i
like what you said about reed and
palamala what they can do in the past
game
ben 921 what would aaron rodgers have
done
in the new england patriots system and
let's let's do it broadly
the full patriot way the full bill
belichick experience although i think
bill belichick would have
he would have changed his approach that
he used on tom brady if he had aaron
rodgers
in the building yeah listen that's a
valid question though you know how he
would handle the
the culture of new england it's
certainly not as free
and they don't let the quarterback
become king there like aaron rodgers is
in green bay or brett favre was before
him
um listen if it's aaron rodgers maybe
you do
it reminds me to a degree yes i mean
right bill belichick had one of the most
special players of all time so he let
lawrence taylor do whatever he wanted to
do
whatever if you have a quarterback who
is undeniably better than any you've
ever seen
you you you throw your rule book out the
window and the patriot way can take a
hike
that's right there would be more of a
leash for rogers there would be i mean
yes you're right talent talks rogers you
say what you want or whatever
go back as i've always said and listen
to any time new england
plays green bay all bill does is wax
poetically about how awesome aaron
rodgers is
it's all he does and i mean it's it's
like real
so uh you know that that's that's
understandable but like yeah bill can
adjust anybody
i mean we've seen some of the characters
they've had there definitely and i think
he can always find the right balance i
mean yeah you said it he was with
lawrence taylor
i mean has there been any more of a
misfit in a locker room in the history
of football than lawrence taylor and i
say that respectfully
i mean he had a sleeping bag underneath
the film room screen because they knew
maybe he was out partying all night
and they let him lay on the floor and
sleep in the sleeping bag during
meetings as bill would coach the defense
to everybody
you know i've heard stories from all my
dad's teammates where you know build
you got it lawrence and he's laying down
yup got it uh
he's back asleep i mean so yeah i think
he could handle rogers and rogers i
think
you know again you're this guy's trying
to get me killed by the new england fan
base but
they would win six super bowls with
aaron rodgers and of course i believe
they would win more
rogers has been in simple
non-schematical creative type offenses
really until these last two or three
years you heard my complaints when we
started working here
you know there's things where he doesn't
even know what he doesn't know he
he'd see plays with tom brady and go oh
that's what i can't believe that's how
they're coaching it up
that's how you got that guy open all the
time all of that type of stuff so
man roger's in new england yeah i'm
prone to go like if he was in new
england they'd be on a 12 pete right now
that's what i would want to say to that
um i guarantee you this
i i don't think bill belichick ever
called lawrence taylor a complicated
fella and i guarantee you he would not
call
aaron rodgers that um yeah and and he's
always got his players backs too that's
the other thing i mean he may rip you in
the film room or on the practice field
but
one of the reasons he's grumbled grumble
grumble when it's time to talk to
reporters he never wants to give any
negative assessment of any of his
players he'll handle that
privately and separately all right uh
laundry
landry landry snyder can the best
college football team ever beat the
worst
nfl team ever the answer is no first we
have to agree
on the best college football team ever
and the worst nfl team ever i'd say the
worst nfl team ever was the
76 bucks is that fair to say uh you're
probably right i mean i was not alive
you're right but i i would guess i mean
to me in my era i'm more of that lions
team or that browns team
but i think like yeah historically
you're probably right the 76 bucks
no given that that coach john mckay was
asked about his team's execution and
said i'm in favor
of the favorite i'll break the tie and
go with the tampa bay bucks who ended up
i think
they lost 14 in a row and then they lost
a bunch more their second season they
had the all-time i think streak
losses but who's the best college team
who's the best college team of all time
who would we put up against the 76
buccaneers
man i i um i mean i
i guess my mind goes to
those early 2000 miami hurricane teams
maybe the usc teams and maybe
yeah maybe yeah one of them maybe the
florida team
that tim tebow was on i don't it's up
there
but excuse me what i would say to that
is
no the best college team ever cannot
beat
the worst nfl team ever no because
the biggest thing is even as great as
those nf those college teams are
there's still a number of players on the
roster that never will play in the nfl
never and then all these guys on those
bucks teams or these bad teams we're
talking about
were all the best players on their
college teams and all of that
so that's where it'll be different let
alone you're dealing with grown men who
know how to play the game
better compared to young kids who are
still learning and doing stuff like that
too
think you're absolutely right there will
be a weakness to exploit there will be
multiple weaknesses
to exploit on that college team with
nfl caliber players who just happen to
be on the worst team in the nfl
right they're still nfl players and
uh yeah you take the nfl coach
who's going to spot those weaknesses on
the college team and it's going to blow
everything up and the college team isn't
going to be able to do the things it
wants to do i agree with you on that all
right
laughing beaver 4 if you had 100 swings
could you hit a home run over the green
monster
i'll say no for me could you well i'm a
lefty so i have to go opposite field
there
but i would like to think that yes i
could
uh you know i don't know i mean i am six
five i'm over 230.
you know i do have a little strength and
muscle in me
i know i played baseball growing up and
everything i'd like to think i could i
know that's not easy
um opposite field i'm not gonna do it
obviously but if the green monster was
to my right side i i i would like to
think i could yes i don't know
i don't know yeah i i
number one i'm also left-handed and
number two uh
i just i know i couldn't do i maybe
there was a time
maybe if i had 100 swings and they would
groove right down the plate
maybe yeah probably not right uh
probably not
all right um i i do have to mention this
one because i've been noticing it the
entire half hour
elle's meet is kurt russell a poor man's
patrick swayze
or is patrick swayze a poor man's kurt
russell
it's a very good question deep thoughts
i don't know like how many
licks to get to the center of a tootsie
roll tootsie pop what did you say
they never know what do you say what is
your what's your thought there
um i would say acting chops
length of career range of characters
yeah
russell is better than pat patrick
swayze
poor man poor man's kurt russell
russell is one of the under-appreciated
actors of our time
that's what i that's what i said i'm i'm
i'm with you there i think i would go
more of the uh
patrick swayze's a poor man's curt
russell
what and and i i got i got i got a soft
spot for kurt russell
my dad used to take me to kurt russell
disney movies in the
early 70s that's how long kurt russell's
been around that's how long
i've been around what movies were that
oh oh trust me i'll i'll send you the
list
kurt the world's strongest man for
example uh
they were all there were multiple kurt
russell young kurt russell
disney movies i think they're all on the
disney plus service we still encourage
peacock
but stop just it's the 70s show you're
talking about sorry
but but uh but anyway and and then kurt
russell
in the hateful eight his role in that
was uh
was incredible yeah it was pretty cool
right so he's been in some cool movies
all right let's take a break i loved
over the overboard with goldie hawn that
was my favorite one growing up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports